uh hi I'm Daniel rackleff I am here with
BuzzFeed and I am going to be answering
some questions while I play with some
puppies bring in the puppets
it's a grieving father yeah yeah
oh wow hind legs straight away a theme
of lifespan of a fact its fact versus
fiction what is the craziest rumor
you've ever heard about yourself I heard
that I had got the SAS to work my dog's
the the most elite military force in the
UK I also heard that I was having beer
brewed by monks in Belgium in a
monastery especially because I'm so
specific about the beer I liked it was
other than a drink in years at this
point so that's what I thought was then
did you keep anything from the Harry
Potter set yes I did keep the glasses
from the Harry Potter I kept one pair of
glasses and I thinking like other little
bits and pieces props that I stole along
the way can you explain why you don't
really use social media yeah because it
seems really stressful I never see
somebody going oh I just checked my
Twitter and this great thing happened or
like I can't wait to get on to Facebook
tonight it would just be another thing
to do I can barely keep up with email
like um I'm quite happy to just like see
my friends when I see them and what's
happened in their life will be a
surprise rather than something I read
about already
oh that's not the kind of thing rushing
to Jimmy tip cuz he's got a white tip on
his tail Susanna and Florence who knows
why what is your go-to karaoke song the
real Slim Shady
I probably shouldn't mention because now
people will go to that YouTube video but
it exists so you would have found it
anyway eventually whit death in Harry
Potter was the hardest for you to get
over was serious definitely was was the
eyelid also because it meant that ie at
the time like I didn't know if I'd be
working with Gary Oldman again and that
was very sad and I adored Gary and
working with him was an incredibly
formative experience in my life the
character's death has come so out of the
blue as well it's like yeah that was a
real shocker
when are you and Elijah would finally
gonna do a project about brothers or
mistaken identity
what is that dance you're doing that's
great I don't know I would love to do
something with Elijah Wood where we play
brothers I don't know if he'd be up for
it but I can only speak myself but I'm
I'm I'm on board
whoever wrote that question you go write
the script what is your favorite thing
about being on Broadway I sound like a
cheesy answer but like the Broadway
community as a whole they just want to
you know and get you into the into the
community and make you feel welcome when
is the last time you watched a Harry
Potter movie I think maybe a premiere
but maybe at the premiere of the last
one I've seen bits and pieces of them
since what is this why the growl at okay
alright yeah I have a level who was your
celebrity crush growing up I mean air a
few the first like picture of a girl I
sort of had like poster ago I have on my
wall was this was Cameron Diaz
I was pretty infatuated by Kirsten Dunst
on fresh sauce actually of course he'll
get over it and then I'll fry sauce
spider-man
those were the two yeah that upside that
whole upside-down kiss moment think that
that that that was a moment for a lot of
us instead of poppies which mad equip
magical creature would you want to play
with while you answer fan questions if
you could dragons I'd want to answer
five questions while I'm playing with
dragons oh that's a very rude question
to ask in front of the puppies please
but if you could have one hobb jet from
the Wizarding World what would it be
maybe just like the the Holograms of
myself because I find it quite creepy
and would rather I contained it not the
rest of the world what is the best
personal or career advice you have ever
gotten my dad gave me a great piece of
advice once which is when you meet
people to get your hand out first
I guess like create an impression of
enthusiasm to meet people and it gets
you off on the right foot and yeah I've
always sort of done that and stuck to it
and it's so far you know I think it's
yeah that's a good one it is adopter
shelter built month all of these amazing
adorable puppies who do not want to sit
in my lap right now from the ASPCA and
if you would like help finding a home
for one of these fantastic and wriggly
but very cute dogs go to ASPCA org full
a to find your Fido to give one of these
wonderful creatures a home and you don't
have to give them the names I did you
can find them this has been fantastic
fun thank you very much for watching
thank you very much for your questions
and please if you are so inclined come
and see the show lifespan of a fact at
Studio 54 thanks very much and see you
next time
wolves wolves next time
[Music]